So 1 elegant answer to this problem was proposed by Nathan Bell and Michael Garland
at the Supercomputing Conference in 2009,
and their answer was, use both approaches, and here's how we're going to do that.
We're going to divide the matrix into 2 pieces.
One piece, the more regular piece, is going to use the thread per row approach.
This right side here, the more irregular approach,
is instead going to use the thread per element approach.
And then we compute each of these separately
and add the results back together at the very end.
So the final question is, where do we draw this line?
What happens if we draw it too far to the left or draw it too far to the right?